[Music]
some days it just hits me how amazing it
is that we all still live together and
what's really crazy is that we're still
in the house we all grew up in what are
the usually when you're still living in
your parents house after 30 years you'd
be considered a bunch of losers but we
don't pay rent so we're winners so many
things have changed in 30 years I know
who would have thought that I would fall
in love with Kimmy's brother and then
I'd be a bridesmaid at Steve's wedding
which tie do you like better who cares
no one looking at the probe it's been 30
years since Uncle Jesse and Joey moved
in with us Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so sweeping you guys came up here
to celebrate the day we all became a
family and you're wearing the same
outfits actually I'm the only one
wearing the same outfit these guys got
bigger sizes how rude buried in Japan
you do know that there's a really nice
Benihana right around the corner Jackson
are you ready to eat that history final
I know all the answers go ahead ask me
anything about Hamilton how do I get
tickets it's impossible that's correct
he was really getting married and not to
you which is fine if you happen to hate
fairy tales and happy endings
hey Jesse I need your help pretend
you're cute guys ouch
you know what I mean pretend you're a
young guy you guys ready to rock
[Music]
you're really very not to be Airport
well answer her
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]